[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to our city
today's episode is a little bit of an
oddball compared to the rest of the
episodes since so far they've been
really focused on making large city
blocks and sections of the city happen
whereas this episode I'm just going to
be working almost one roundabouts and
the surrounding area
I'll definitely still get into some city
blocks and doing some detailing but the
focus of the episode is not a single
roundabout and I know that probably
sounds really weird so allow me to
explain this very quickly for one this
runabout is very important for the city
itself it is actually where the highway
that connects the city to the rest of
the world ends which makes it important
I guess in two ways for that because for
one I wanted this to look as good as
possible so that when you're getting
into the city you can actually see the
skyline as you're approaching this
roundabout and you have a park in the
middle
it all looks super fancy there's
actually a special special little trick
or I guess you could call Easter Egg
that I put into it that we'll get into
later on but basically it's very much
about the aesthetics it's getting an
interesting almost wayfinding kind of
ideas into this roundabout where when
you approach the roundabout you really
feel like you're entering the city
itself but also it's pretty important
traffic wise since obviously I have a
highway that's ending pretty close to
the downtown of the city already so I
also wanted to make sure that this thing
could actually handle quite some traffic
in the future when all the cards or all
of the cars that want to enter the city
are going to have to pass through this
thing so they're kind of dispersing into
these two different directions depending
on where in the city you want to go so
hopefully that should allow for a pretty
smooth transition from the approaching
highway into
wrote of the city so when I come to that
it should be pretty good as well but
also aside from this run about being
important for the city itself I also
fell it was very important for me to try
and got this roundabout because I
haven't really done so much
experimentation so far with the move it
mod or using road probes to really
customize your roads even though that
was one of the things which I started
doing like the minutes that move it to
and the fine prop
I think it's called fine pocket or
something the mode that allows you to
place props in a line in a very fine
line but basically that were some of the
first things that I tried doing but I
haven't really done it since so I really
feel I need some practice before I
actually get into the real work which
will in the future be some highway
junctions or airports for the city so
before I get into those larger projects
I still want to make sure that I have a
grasp of the mechanics and also a bit of
an idea of the style that I want to go
for in the city so this is almost like a
prototype of what's going to happen
later on the new city and for that for
me it's pretty important now obviously
there is already quite a bit of have
funny stuff happening with the
roundabout that you might have noticed
for one it's made out of highway Road
reason that I wanted to do that is it
means you don't have to deal with any of
those crosswalks which are super
annoying and ugly on the roundabouts and
you don't get them on the highway only
problem with the highway is you get cars
speeding over it and you also have that
dirt on the side so I'm just going to
set restrictions on the speed and you
might already have noticed that I just
brushed some concrete on the side to
make sure that I don't have to deal with
the dirt on the side and this actually
looks like a road which would be in the
middle of the city so those are two
problems alleviated I guess and what's
also sort of interesting about the
roundabout is shape-wise
I also wanted to make sure that it's as
neat as possible and
it's just a very simple two-lane
roundabouts not really anything special
going on there but the exits and the
entries are still kind of curving along
with it just to make sure that you can
actually keep a pretty decent speed and
hopefully to make this both a pretty
nice-looking runabout and a pretty
efficient runabout at some point in the
future there is still some stuff that
I'm going to experiment with when it
comes to the roundabouts in a little bit
but first I wanted to get some buildings
in on the side just to get an idea of
how that's always going to look it's a
little bit inspired by the roundabouts
that you see in many European cities
where these traffic circles like the
circuses in London or in Paris are
really some of those all are not really
squares I think London still cause some
of them squares anyway where these open
round places the roundabouts are really
cool ever used in the city that's
basically an idea I wanted to sort of
emulate with this roundabouts and what
makes that extra special is that I
actually put the Pearl which is from an
actual run about a mosque right in the
middle of the roundabout here so that's
a little touch that should hopefully
make it feel a little bit closer to
reality even if it doesn't really mean
that much it's just it's one of the few
assets one of the very very few assets
that actually fit the theme of what I'm
going for here so I definitely had to
put that thing in there because though
if there was anything that fits in here
that I should have put in there it was
definitely this now at this point I am
working on the road markings and you
might notice that I'm doing some weird
stuff at first and I'm now redoing the
road markings so the reason for that was
that I actually did a bit of research
when it comes to two-lane run a box
because most of the roundabouts over
here in the Netherlands are either
regular ones or turbo roundabouts and
there aren't too many regular two-lane
roundabouts anymore they still are but
they're just simple roundabouts and I
was looking for a slightly more
sophisticated kind of approach to doing
the markings and I found on the
I found a New Zealand research on the
Alberta roundabout which I had never
heard of but it's a roundabout which
surprisingly is used in Alberta New
Zealand and what makes it kind of
special I guess is really just the
markings that you can see over there
with the straight lines as you enter the
roundabouts and the dotted lines
continuing on from the roundabouts to
the roads that you're going to go exit
the roundabout from now I at first
actually messed this up because I
literally just copied a scheme that I
found on some research articles but I
completely forgot that New Zealand has
left them driving so I had a left hand
driving markings on my right-hand
driving city that wasn't working out too
well but by now it's all lesson driving
now the interesting thing about this as
by the way I'm working on these
pedestrian paths by E but I eventually
ended up removing these because they
turn out to be a little bit messy I
would have loved to have a way to sort
of bypass the road here but it's not
going to happen with these things they
don't look all that great I wish there
were some ways to make these things a
little bit more aesthetically pleasing
but when they look like this I would
rather just go with none at all
then be forced to go with some awkward
pedestrian roads that somehow that white
fan is also using anyway so I did find
some research on the roundabouts and it
wasn't actually all that great the
research is actually still inconclusive
like there are some differences when it
comes to using this roundabout compared
to a regular two-lane roundabouts but
it's not actually statistically
significant so I guess New Zealand had
two roundabouts in a bit of a weird
fashion that aren't all that necessary
though then again I'm not a roundabout
expert I just got this from some
research articles but it was actually a
very interesting read because they were
comparing regular two-lane roundabouts
the spiral clones to Alberta runabout
but the difference ended up not really
existing too much at least it was
statistically significant so this
roundabout kind of fashion here is
really all just to look fancy and there
aren't any theories then I guess really
support the usage of it especially over
turbo roundabout I just think that in
game this is a pretty good looking way
of doing the markings on the roundabouts
so that's why I went for it now I'm
behind your little bit boots I've got
the park in the middle already done with
Pro and I wanted to talk about this
besides I'm going into buildings now
which is you know all of those the reco
putting using Rico to put buildings and
intersect them and make rows that have
done since beginning of the series so I
actually wanted to talk about the park a
little bit more because I found this
book called paradoxes of green and it
talks about things that I've also
touched on in this series earlier and I
found generally online quite a bit but
in a much more concise and in one place
and very interesting research assembly I
don't actually have the book my VPN
university doesn't really give me access
to it which is super unfortunate and I'm
too poor to actually buy it I might
still it is super interesting but
basically the author went to befriend
and study the way that green spaces are
perceived over there but it really
compares to countries like United Arab
Emirates or Qatar as well in that what's
interesting in these places is that
there is this huge clash between the dry
desert landscapes that these countries
naturally have and the overly green lush
foliage that you find inside the cities
because the many of the cities you'll
find perfectly capped longs of beautiful
grass and European trees and amazing
gardens like you would find in any
country in North America but it's all in
the middle of a desert and there's kind
of this idea that all of these perfectly
manmade nature natural kind of gardens
are green and that nature isn't green at
all because nature in these countries is
just
sand desert with the occasional shrubs
and date-palms and I thought that was
very interesting because there is also
this clash between those two landscapes
and this is also what the name of the
book refers to in that the nature that
you'll find in all these cities the
gardens and parks that you'll find in
Bahrain are green in terms of color but
they're not actually green in terms of
being natural and environmentally
sustainable they're green but they're
not really green at all and that's
basically my challenge for our city and
I think it's better put and more
concisely put then I've ever done so far
in my own videos that's kind of the
challenge that I wanted to take on with
Armour City as well because obviously I
don't want the city to be treeless trees
or super important entities to cool them
down a bit to provide some shade
especially in a climate like this and to
even make the Arabic clinics make them
altogether better cities to live but
this is also a city in the middle of the
desert and that makes things quite hard
I didn't want to go for a natural kind
of look that the real cities I like to
buy or gohan have because it's not
sustainable I wanted to go kind of for
both greens to have both green foliage
around the city while at the same time
making sure that it is actually nature
and that it's actually environmentally
sustainable so I'm not sure how exactly
I would fix this it is of course a huge
question and I'm just around them the
European guy who's making videos of city
skylines but still it's something that I
wanted to take with me when I was
building this city and that's also why a
lot of the stuff that I have in the city
so far is really serious caping in a
sense that it shouldn't require any or
too much water and it should more or
less care for itself and that's also why
the middle of the roundabout might look
like a total mess if you look at any
roundabouts in Dubai or
they're going to be having beautiful
grass lawns and amazing patterns in the
middle of them maybe have some
beautifully arranged flowers and trees
and stuff that's all really okay sir
it's just a collection of bushes on a
slightly sandy gravelly dirt ish kind of
patch of land and basically because I
was hoping that this would look good
while at the same time still being
someone sustainable it's probably not as
good-looking as some beautifully
arranged flowers or huge huge patches of
grass that you would see but it should
hopefully at the same time be a bit more
natural and keep the city a bit more
sustainable the problem is I just didn't
want to make any nature that it is
really nature at all and I also didn't
want to I guess make parks that are
almost like carbon copies of European
parks when really that shouldn't really
work in a climate like this so that's
the idea also outside of the deserts and
I've sort of been looking into this I'm
definitely not sure how well it's going
to pan out but outside in the deserts
and not always in the city itself is
where hopefully foliage wise I can make
an actual breakthrough and maybe get
into some making the desert a little bit
more green there are definitely quite a
bit of projects going on in the real
world to try and plant trees in deserts
and see how you can naturally reverse
the desertification that's happening all
around the world and those things as
well or way too high-tech for meat but
it's still something that I would love
to mess with Emma City just as an idea
and to see the city has a sort of
perfect utopian model actually be true
to that sort of name so yeah I have
pretty much almost finished three
buildings around the roundabout at this
point which me quite happy with how the
buildings work out here I did change a
couple of buildings like I now have
these two smaller high-rise buildings
near the entrance because I wanted to
have two towers that sort of create this
gate as you come in from the highway but
the buildings that I had before were a
little bit too over
it felt like they were dwarfing the rest
of the buildings in terms of size and
scope and that didn't really work out
too well
now also I've replaced some of the
buildings after doing some of some
off-screen work trying to mess with
stuff and trying to combine different
buildings because as much as I I do want
to keep one style throughout the city I
also want to diversify a bit but I've
pretty much just used all of the
buildings in this style that we have on
the workshop so there really isn't too
much to do with this anymore and it's
hard to make the city look diverse
throughout the entire city while still
using the same palette of building maybe
every once in two weeks there's a few
new buildings that I can pick up again
and put into the city but it's really
not too much so you can really see some
of the same buildings come back at this
point hopefully it's not too big of an
issue though but it's it's kind of a
hard thing to get around especially with
some of these high-rises I'm really
really like running out of these sort of
100 to 150 meters tall high-rises then I
have so many in the city of because I've
already used many in this style and
there really isn't that much more in the
workshops so those issues are definitely
going to play up here anyway that is
just about it for the gig time lapse so
I'm gonna thank you guys for watching
this time that's so far but I also want
to end this video with a special mention
to kingly no because once I checked out
the workshop very recently and I found a
asset called the villas Omar city I was
like I was flabbergasted they are so
cool it's a really cool building and
King we know in general has given many
of the efforts and a lot of the way that
Mississippi looks so far so to see an
actual building for the city itself with
the name in it is absolutely amazing I
haven't really used it too much in this
episode but these shots should probably
prove how good this building is and
you'll definitely see it returning a bit
more in the future so yeah special
mention to that I also want to say
strict toaster for actually giving me a
texture recently he gave me the textures
for his new project called senior a
while back before he was even announced
and the textures are really amazing I
definitely don't want to argue with that
only thing was I've already sort of set
the theme for on my city so far and I
which is looking for a new kind of same
texture and as you might have noticed I
actually switched to yet another semtex
too except this one is slightly darker
but it is still my own same texture and
then actually take strict doses but one
of the see new textures that being the
cliffside one where it's sort of clear
the dune sand ish texture to it is one
that I will be using and then I have put
into the theme for the city so you'll
see that come back at some point in
future I haven't been able to really
show it off yet so this is just an empty
shadow without much to it but you'll
definitely see that pop up in the future
and especially as we get into the desert
itself that texture should help us quite
a lot to make this project look
believable so yeah thanks again to those
guys and thanks again to you as a viewer
for watching this video I hope you
enjoyed and I'll see you next time